اذا الان مياده الى انطاكيا نعود مره اخرى
انطاكيا معنا من هناك مراسل الجزيره
المعتز
بالحسن معتز ضعنا في صوره اخر ما لديك من
معلومات وهل اي مؤشرات على انه ما زال
هناك احياء تحت الانقاذ اذا تسمعني معتز
تسمعني الان
اذا سنعود لك المعتز بالله حسن حتى على ما
يتم تجاوز اسمعني الان بشكل جيد عبد
القادر ولكن
تفضل ان كنت تسمعني فنحن هنا في محافظه
هاتاي مدينه انطاكيا الوضع هنا في محافظه
هاتاي هو وضع ربما يكون من اصعب اوضاع
المدن التي
شهدت هذا الزلزال كانت شده الزلزال 7.7
والثاني 7.6 ما سبب في انهيار
اكثر من الفين مبنى خلفي في هذا الموقع
يمكن ان نشاهد عمليات ازاله الالقاب
والبحث عن ناجين ما زالت مستمره في هذا
المكان هناك عده ابنيه تدمرت في هذا
المكان ربما الاساسيان هم بناءان
عاليان من عشره طوابق لكن يمكن مشاهده في
الصوره ان الابنيه الاخرى هي ايضا حالتها
صعبه جدا هناك تصدعات في جميع المباني لم
يعد بالامكان بالتاكيد ان يعود احد من
السكان الى هذه
المباني هناك العديد من فرق المتطوعين
التي وصلت الى
محافظه اطاي ولكن على ما يبدو ان الوضع هو
صعب جدا لانتشار انهيار المباني في كافه
انحاء المدينه حتى انه يقال انه
معظم الابنيه في المدينه هي ربما
تاثرت بهذا الزلزال بشكل او اخر طبعا عدد
القتلى وصل في هذا الزلزال حتى الان بحسب
الارقام الرسميه الى
19000 قتيل و75,000 جريح
هناك بحسب محافظه هاتاي واداره الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه تم البدء بتشييد مقابر
ارقام
لدفن جثث الضحايا التي انتشرت من تحت
الانقاض
وبحسب اداره الطوارئ والكوارث فان صلاه
الجنازه تقام على كل جثمان على حده قبل ان
يوارى الثرى كانت اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه قد اعلنت انهم
سيضطرون لدفن الجثث التي لا يتم التعرف
عليها بعد 24 ساعه من انتشارها وذلك منعا
لتقدس الجثث
وجثث امام المشافي والمراكز الصحيه طبعا
نقطه اخرى مهمه في مدينه هاتاي هي انه
كثير من المشافي هي
تعرضت الانهيار كامل او جزئي نتيجه هذا
الزلزال وهو ما زاد الضغط على موضوع
الاسعاف
ومساعده الضحايا هناك فرق متطوعين بكثره
في مدينه حطاي ولكن الوقت
هو المشكله والوقت هو الحرج لان هناك كانت
تاخر في ربما بحسب بعض
الذين قبلناهم تاخر في الوصول الى مدينه
هاتاي ربما بسبب الاضرار التي شهدتها
الطرقات او بسبب الظروف المناخيه
طيب المعتز ان كنت تسمعنا هذا المبنى الذي
خلفك هل هناك اي امال بان يكون تحته لازال
هناك احياء يمكن ان يخرجوا من تحت الانقاض
تحدثت مع بعض المنقذين الموجودين في
المكان قبل قليل وسالتهم هذا السؤال هل
هناك امكانيه لوجود بعد كل هذا الزمن
الجواب هو الذي اسمعه دائما الامل لا
ينقطع ولكننا لم نعد نسمع اصواتا وبالتالي
اليوم العمل هو اثقل بكثير من العمل خلال
الايام الماضيه نستطيع ان نشاهد ان
الاليات الثقيله هي ايضا موجوده في المكان
وهي تعمل هناك
كثير من الاشخاص موجودين لكن يتحدث
بعض الذين هم متطوعون هنا بانه قد لا يوجد
فرق خبيره بشكل كاف لاداره هذا النوع من
عمليات الانقاذ لان الفرق الفرق المتطوعه
هي تحاول جهدها الوصول الى الناس الذين هم
موجودون تحت الانقاد لكن الفرق الخبيره هي
مباشره تعمل على انشاء ممر حياه وهذا
الممر الحياه تستطيع من خلاله مباشره
انقاذ الناس عبر بيتي اماكنهم سواء كان
ذلك بالصوت او باستخدام الاجهزه الحراريه
ربما هذا هو الوضع في مدينه هاتاي مدينه
هاتاي التي كانت اكثر من تالم ربما من شده
الزلزال الذي وقع فجر الاثنين الماضي بشده
بلغت 7.7 ومن بعدها زلزال ثاني كان هو
الزلزال الذي
هدمت فيه كثير من الابنيه شكرا لك المعتز
بالعسل